sur les étudiants ou dessous dans ce jeu
vous confirme qu'il ya pas besoin de
décret par contre je vous confirme que
son décret nous l'avons commencée et
amplifier il ya 200 internes qui sont en
poste actuellement dans les zones sous
denses selon le mécanisme que le sénat
effectivement apportées à la loi au tsg
revenir sur le point évoqué par mon
collègue rené paul savary et sur ce que
le sénat a voté dans la loi sur relative
à l'organisation la transformation du
système de santé en 2019
j'ai l'impression qu'on se comprend pas
excusez moi vous avez répondu d'ailleurs
à rené paul savary qui avait pas besoin
de décret d'un gamin besoin d'un pour
certaines spécialités si vous le
souhaitez parce qu'il ya des tensions en
médecine générale mais il ya aussi des
tensions dans certaines spécialités et
si vous voulez intégrer cette obligation
de deux moins six mois
pardon si si c'est dans la loi
mentionnant pas dans la version votée à
l'assemblée nationale la version
définitive mais fabrice a été retirée
l'obligation je pense que lundi si
l'enfant s'était pas vraiment mais c'est
bien d'avoir voté la notion d'obligation
de stage en dessous dans sa a été
supprimée au profit d'une notion d'
incitation en zones sous denses étaient
dans la dernière mouture de l'os
il semble qu'en en commission mixte
paritaire où c'était un point dur pour
nous et qu'on ne veut rien lâcher alors
je sais bien que côté ministère personne
n'en voudrait côté l'assemblée nationale
personne n'en voulait
côté étudiants en médecine personne n'en
voulait on est bien d'accord mais il ya
quand même une réalité et vous voyez le
temps passe vite
l' avantage de la loi votée en 2019
il faut savoir que il est normal qu'elle
ne pouvait s'imposer s'appliquer aux
internes en médecine avant ceux qui
rentraient qui sont rentrés en première
année d'internât de métier générale au
1er novembre 2019
ça veut dire qu'ils vont rentrer en
troisième année au 1er novembre 2000 21
dont je ne doute pas de votre chiffre de
220 en interne en stage mais j'ai dire
ça c'est la maquette ancien ancienne
mouture
si la loi s'applique bien des internes
en dernière année médecine générale me
semble-t-il de mémoire il y en à 3506
pendant au moins
six mois ils viennent au moins pendant
six mois en dans le même dans le même
cabinet médical dans la même maison de
santé en autonomie superviser en renfort
des médecins déjà installé maître de
stage ou pas maître de stage d'ailleurs
ça a été une discussion qu'on avait
qu'on avait âprement évoqué c'est 35
étudiants en dernière année dans la
dernière ligne droite de leurs études en
médecine générale qui peuvent venir en
renfort de médecins déjà installé pas au
milieu ne part pas tout seul bien sûr
mais en renfort de mais je pense que le
sujet est important
et moi je voudrais savoir si oui ou non
la maquette va évoluer qu'elle va
s'appliquer au 1er novembre 2021 pour
que ses étudiants qui seront dernières
années d'internât messi général puisse
venir au moins six mois en renfort des
praticiens déjà installés
bien sûr dans les zones sous denses en
lien avec le zonage déterminé par les
agences régionales de santé je vous
remercie
fabrice humbert j'ai la rédaction
précise si vous le souhaitez du texte
tel qu'il a été adopté
je vais vous le trouver
en lan ou si vous voulez voilà je suis
tu je remercie sa maman le déploiement
tout au long des études de médecine
d'une offre de stage dans les zones
caractérisées par une offre de soins
insuffisante ou des difficultés dans
l'accès aux soins défini en application
de l'article l 14 34 erika du code de
santé publique fait l'objet d'une
évaluation tous les trois ans par les
ministres chargés de la santé de
l'enseignement supérieur cette évolution
est transmise au parlement et sur la
rédaction en réalité sur ce qui restait
à l'issue du la fin du texte
l'inter en médecine générale effectué un
stage préférentiellement en zones sous
denses dans sa dernière année d'internât
si on n'est pas d'accord le contenu de
la loi kg oui m'autorise je vous parle
de l'article 2 l'article 2 de cette loi
monsieur le ministre
où il est dit alors attendez il faut que
je les étudiants de médecine générale
réalise au cours de la dernière année du
troisième cycle de médecine au minimum
un stage d'un semestre en pratique
ambulatoires sous le régime d'autonomie
supervise en fait je les raccourcis là
mais c'est ça le deuxièmement de
l'article 2 de la loi je pense qu'on ne
parle pas de la même chose c'est bien
pour ça que je suis revenu sur sur les
ponts ça le stage en ambulatoire
oui mais il ya le stage en ambulatoire
fait partie de la maquette des internes
qui est obligatoire et le stage de oblig
est obligatoire d'une soudan qui étaient
retirés de la loi avec l'engagement dans
l'agenda rural de développer à terme 400
places pour des internes en ambulatoire
enfin d'internât en zone rurale et en
zones sous denses où nous en sommes déjà
à 200 nous travaillons sur la maîtrise
de stage pour pouvoir déployer d'autres
termes ça qu'on monte à 400 côté je moi
je vous parle de l'article 2 de la loi
voilà et je crois qu'on ne parle pas la
preuve vous me lisez que je jeûne ou
parce que vous misez c'est bien la loi
mais on n'est pas au même endroit on
parle pas de la même chose et moi je
parle vraiment d'un stage en autonomie
superviser d'au moins six mois qui a
fait débat je vous le promets je
connaisse je connais les oppositions à
la fois de la ministre de l'assemblée
national des internes mais c'était
justement le point concret
très pragmatique d'une disposition mise
dans la loi qui pouvait avoir une
application à court terme puisque deux
ans après ça peut être mis en place et
elle s'applique aux 3500 internes en
médecine générale
donc moi je suis à votre disposition
pour qu'on en reparle mais je vous
promets que c'était sable sujet mais
j'm'en aussi pardonnez moi je travaille
avec des avec d autres d administration
qui sont beaucoup plus compétentes que
moi et qui travaillent dessus au
quotidien permanent
on reprend les choses vous avez les
internes de médecine générale doivent
réaliser un semestre en ambulatoire à la
fin de leur maquette ça c'est fait et
c'est la règle ça c'est fait et c'est la
règle ensuite il a encouragé les
internes des spécialités d'organes a
réalisé des stages en milieu ambulatoire
vers la fin de la maquette et ça nous y
travaillons au développement des
maîtrises de stage qui n'existe pas
encore aujourd'hui et la notion
d'obligation quelle qu'elle soit dans
les dents que ce soit pour avoir des
stages en ambulatoire des stages en
dessous de danse n'a pas été retenu dans
la rédaction de la loi
alors moi c'est un truc qui dit on c'est
un article qui dit les étudiants en
médecine générale réalise au cours de la
dernière année du troisième cycle de
médecine au minimum un stage d'un sommet
sans pratiquer ambulatoire ce stage est
réalisé dans les lieux à gré en priorité
dans les zones mentionnées au 1er de
l'article 1 du code de santé publique
il est effectué sous un régime
d'autorisation d'autonomie superviser et
cette pratique ambulatoire peut être
étendue par décret à d'autres
spécialités exercice majoritairement vu
la toile enfin un moment quand cela
réjouit c'est que les airs de meeting
loeb derrière toi l'auteur de médecine
générale dans les dernières années font
un stage en ambulatoire avec un maître
de stage qu'on appelle autonomie
superviser
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça me fait la loi
vous savez quoi on va faire une réunion
avec la dg os avec des gens avec des
doyens si vous voulez mais tous les
acteurs vous leur direz que c'est pas ça
puis vous en discuterait avec eux et moi
je serai là mais on ne peut pas passer
il heureux si je vous dis qu'on n'a pas
la même lecture de la loi
donc on n'a pas la même lecture de la
loi ça arrive mais obliger toutes les
administrations les universités etc
lesquels on travaille pour le déployer
qui ont la même lecture de la loi que
moi donc si vous voulez on n'en voudra
1.1 poitrine à mort à vérifier ça parce
que ça me va pas passer on va pas passer
le l'audition là-dessus mais il ya quand
même une incompréhension totale entre ce
que nous on a pu voter est ce qui est
investi
non voilà on s'est fait avoir sur la
rédaction je plaisante
allez on continue les réponses aux
questions des en ce qui concerne en ce
qui concerne le projet de loi qui a été
acceptée par le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale qui a décrit corinne imbert
donc c'est un amant mangue qui est
devenu un amendement de la commission et
moi gérons j'étais à côté d'un million
quand il a reçu d un terme au départ
c'était un an puis après on a négocié
j'étais là six mois et c'était
obligatoire en dernière année de
troisième cycle mais ça peut être
changée à l'assemblée nationale j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas c'est resté
comme ça
et monsieur le ministre quand vous
parlez de 400 vous confondez avec ma
santé 2022 ou madame busan avait dit il
y aura 400 praticiens qui iront dans les
hôpitaux périphériques et qui iront dans
les zones sous denses
[Musique]